Jim, we've managed to sneak into the premises of the house.
As we can see,
death, definitely
reigns supreme.
There's no sense of morals anywhere here, Jim. If there was, then surely
we would know that there was-- police, justice, crime in the city, oh--
*loud huffing, with slight background squeaking*
Jim...
I've got eyes on the murderer!
Maybe not, though. But we can't be sure of anything after this point.
So...
It is entirely possible, Jim, that this is the Detective who is gathering clues,
But little does he know, we have been doing some clue gathering of our own.
Take, for example:
The stray pattern of the fecal matter on this turret, hasn't been cleaned for a while.
The Butler may be neglecting his du-tees.
What is...
Ooh, not good...
That must be his firearm, right.
I can only imagine that her name is Sasha, named after his former lover that he lost 23 years ago to this day.
And that's the...
Look at the way he handles Sasha.
Only a man experienced as a lover could use such a thing!
But need we forget that we also found some stray hairs that may have been animal related.
But I suspect that they were part of this insidious plot to murder whoever the hell
lives in this goddamn home.
But WE will get to the bottom of it.
I swear that on you, Jim and Jim and Jim-back-at-home and our Mother, Jim.
Wait! A development!
I'm gonna get a better look!
What do you see, Jim?
Could it be the pictures of his victims?
Or mayhaps... something.. more sinister!
His family members' parents,
or even...
Uh..
It's a portable DVD player.. filled with sad movies.
Oh, what a tragedy to do to yourself!
Remember our cousin Jim, Jim?
He would often flay himself alive to sad movies, such as "The Passion of the Christ".
Jim, some new development, Jim.
Something has changed in his...
I think he sees us, Jim!
We're losing him...we... we gotta go, Jim, we gotta go! C'mon!
JIMMM!
[here we see jim in his natural habitat]
[watch as he dances]
Stay low!
(( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°))